so yesterday Donald Trump viciously
snapped at a nurse who is just the nurse
she's not a politician she was just
telling the truth as she experienced it
which was that she had had only sporadic
access to PPE like masks and gowns and
face shields and Trump didn't like it
Trump did his thing where he crosses his
arms like a petulant child and he
snapped at her and said well maybe your
access was sporadic but that's not what
I'm hearing take a look at the video so
PPE has been a sporadic but it's been
manageable and we do what we have to do
we're nurses and we learn to adapt and
do whatever the best thing that we can
do for our patients to get the job done
and get the care provided and that's
what we're going to continue to do as
hope in 19 continues sporadic sporadic
mr. president because I've heard the
opposite I've heard that they are loaded
up with with gowns now and you know
initially we had nothing we had empty
cupboards
she wasn't even saying anything that bad
right I mean access to PPE has been
sporadic but manageable she says it's
not like a huge attack on Trump it's not
really an attack on Trump at all but
Trump says well maybe it was sporadic
for you but not for other people oh yes
yes yes mr. president she says and of
course Donald Trump claims this is all
because of the empty cupboards that
Barack Obama left him and this has to be
called out now when Trump says the PPE
problems were because the cupboards were
bare Trump's had three and a half years
now how is it still even if you accept
it was Obama's fault which is ridiculous
but even if you accept it was Obama's
fault that there wasn't PPE when Trump
took over it's been three and a half
years yours Longet Trump couldn't get
masks in three and a half years it's
really really weak weak stuff now I want
to be really clear Trump doing this to a
nurse is completely heartless she's not
a politician this is a nurse who treats
patients doctors have the Hippocratic
oath nurses have the nightingale pledge
named for florence nightingale it's
similar to the Hippocratic oath in a lot
of ways it says in short don't do
anything that but might be bad for
patients take care of sick people
that's what nurses do she has had
sporadic access to PPE and Trump can't
accept it without a rebuttal and
snapping at her now I don't blame the
nurse for what I'm about to say she's
not a politician she's a nurse it would
be great if someone in one of these
situations instead of saying yes yes yes
mr. president of course it would be
better if they said you've been
misinformed mr. president if that's what
you heard you weren't told the truth I
know the truth because I'm on the front
lines
I'm not criticizing this nurse it's not
her job to go there and to criticize
Donald Trump but it would be great for
someone to publicly do it a health
worker in the room with Trump it would
go instantly viral if they were to do it
but last thing Trump again during this
photo-op brings up the entire we've done
more tests than anyone lie let's take a
look at that I watched this phony Chuck
Schumer everyone in New York knows he's
a total phony he brought nothing back to
New York except salt you know what salt
is bad tax policy he brought salt back
he didn't even fight it
I watched him the other night on a show
and all he could talk about was testing
testing testing
and yet I showed a chart yesterday where
our testing is far superior to anybody
else's testing and then the other thing
is very interesting because we did so
much more testing we have more cases if
I did a little testing we'd have
practically no cases so the headline was
we have more cases than anyone else well
China has more cases than US and other
big countries giving you're talking
about big countries but they don't want
to choose they don't want to use that so
I know I'm sounding like a broken record
I will continue to fact chess packed
check this for as long as Donald Trump
and Kaylee Mac and Annie and everybody
else keep lying about it we do not have
enough testing we are not the best in
the world at testing we are 41st in
testing in the world per capita 7
million tests don't matter if you have
331 million people Iceland is second in
the world in per-capita testing Israel
is 13th in the world in per-capita
testing Portugal is 15 Spain is 20th
Norway is 20
sixth we are 41st in the world in per
capita
coronavirus testing in terms of tests
per day remember health experts have
said we need to at least get to 500,000
tests a day to even think about opening
and over the last 10 days or so we can't
get past an average of 250,000 tests per
day so after 2 months of this we are in
really three months we are just now
getting halfway to the absolute minimum
number we need to think about opening
and 500,000 tests today is just a
starting point we ideally would pass
500,000 a day on route to a million a
day on route to 2 million tests a day
Trump is failing hugely it's tragic it's
embarrassing but he's snapping at nurses
who tell the truth back briefly to the
PPE thing there are health care workers
who are dying because they're getting
the virus there are health care workers
in places that still are rationing PPE
wearing masks longer than they should
for example and Trump who has been
president for three and a half years is
simultaneously saying there's more than
enough PPE but also saying any shortage
is because Obama left the cupboards bare
even though it's been three and a half
years it has to stop I've got something
really cool today the first 500 people
who see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months for free skill shares the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore
something totally new and like I said
the first 500 people who see this video
and go to david pakman.com slash skill
will get a completely free premium
membership for two months giving you
access to every class Skillshare offers
check it out i put the link right
underneath this video